thousands of residents in a Southeast
Texas town rocked by a pair of
explosions are returning home this
weekend authorities say a massive
chemical plant fire is now considered
contained a mandatory evacuation order
has been lifted but residents are being
asked to still avoid the area near the
plant as Omar Villafranca reports air
quality is a concern the Parker family
was forced to spend the Thanksgiving
holiday away from home after a
petrochemical plant explosion forced
them and more than 50 thousand other
people to evacuate we've lived here for
30 years and this is first time it's
never ever happens the initial blast
sent giant columns of black smoke and
scorching flames into the southeast
Texas sky the tpc group the plant's
owner says the fire is now contained but
smoke can still be seen coming from the
plant the facility manufactures
butadiene a chemical used to make
synthetic rubber low-level exposure to
the chemical can cause eye and lung
irritation Texas officials say the air
quality it's safe we had nothing about
the threshold limit values that are
established by federal and state
guidelines and no exceedences that pose
hazards to human health this smoke is
still coming from the source where the
explosion happened there is still toxic
fumes in that smoke but environmental
activists Hilton Kelly disagrees we know
for a fact that there's benzene in that
plume we know that there's 1 3 butadiene
and we just discovered that there's also
asbestos in that plume but just how much
is still uncertain at this particular
time and we want to make sure that all
our citizens are safe County officials
say as long as there is smoke coming
from the plant they'll continue to
monitor the air quality for CBS this
morning Saturday Omar Villafranca Dallas